bonjour jim michel gabriel merci d'être
avec nous sur arte france sur facebook
avec plaisir facebook ne semble pas
avoir réussi à restaurer la confiance
perdue après les accusations de
manipulation notamment lors de la
campagne présidentielle américaine de
2016 on se souvient aussi du scandale
cambridge analytique à cette contre
offensive parce que c'est surtout une
opération de relations publiques pour
calmer les critiques ou est-ce qu'on va
véritablement assister un virage
significatif dans la gestion des
publications alors nous les avocats
notamment dans cette spécialité on dit
depuis 2018 qu'il ya un problème sur
facebook et notamment d'une manière
générale sur les réseaux sociaux
facebook en fait le son problème c'est
que soit ils interdisaient il faisait
retrait ou alors ils laissaient faire
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
aujourd'hui le bon fonctionnement il
faudrait qu'ils aient une attitude
beaucoup plus responsable justement pour
que il ya un écosystème un peu plus sûrs
et plus fiables et comme vous pouvez
vous en rendre compte en fait le nerf de
la guerre c'est l'argent parce que la
réalité c'est que par exemple coca cola
ça représente 22 millions
d'investissements publicitaires sur
facebook
c'est colossal unilever pareil qui a
décidé de se retirer
donc à partir de là on voit bien qu'il
ya un vrai débat qui commence déjà
économique
déjà au départ et qui servira
nécessairement aujourd'hui les
discriminations et la lutte contre le
racisme
et c'est là dessus que on se rend compte
que toucher le porte-monnaie en fait ça
fait avancer la cause
on voit que ce sont des grosses
entreprises des multinationales qui font
infléchir la tendance
quel rôle pour les gouvernements les
états là dedans alors c'est bien que les
multinationales se rend compte et occupe
en fait et multinationales c'est parce
qu'elles ont bien compris que leurs
consommateurs sont de toutes couleurs
donc à partir de là il ne peut pas
aujourd'hui se permet ce ne pas se
positionner alors les états mais cet
ajustement
nous on dit depuis 2018 il faut réguler
il faut aujourd'hui une
alors certains se cachent derrière
justement la fameuse liberté
d'expression etc
au bout d'un moment on ne peut pas tout
dire parce que comme vous pouvez vous en
rendre compte
c'est devenu un vrai
vers soir en fait facebook de la haine
et à partir de là ans il faut que ça
s'arrête au bout d'un moment il faut que
l'on soit responsable
on peut pas laisser il faut une certaine
régulation qui doit être mise en place
et si facebook aujourd'hui doit être mis
au pilori
il n'y a pas de raison que le sont pas
alors la problématique c'est que là en
arrive dans le dur de l'élection
américaine
on va voir comment les prochains mois
comment ça va s'organiser en fait et
qu'est ce que le boycott publicitaire et
les annonces de mark zuckerberg
oui je disais qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que le boycott publicité à qu'est-ce que
les annonces de mark zuckerber peuvent
changer à l'économie de facebook je n'ai
pas entendu
oui je vous entends jim michel gabriel
est ce que vous est-ce que vous
m'entendez j'ai pas entendu la question
était savoir qu'est ce que le boycott
publicitaire et les annonces de mark
zuckerberg
qu'est ce que ça peut changer à
l'économie de facebook énorme comme je
voulais dit coca cola ses 22 millions
par an unilever c'est colossal
l'oréal aussi imaginer que ça peut
impacter énormément ses profits est le
slogan qui dit justement stop et ford au
profit est parfaitement illustrateur de
la situation là c'est facebook qui est
impactée est-ce qu'on peut être amené à
voir d'autres réseaux sociaux allaient
dans ce sens comme un conteur par
exemple à battery eater est beaucoup
plus responsable en quelque sorte le
problème c'est que tout le monde il ya
moins de personnes qui sont sur twitter
en fait
et puis le message est plus court etc
mais twitter est beaucoup plus
responsable effectivement que facebook
dans cette situation parce qu'il a tout
de suite été très dures notamment au
regard de messages que car adressé le
président des états unis alors que
facebook a été beaucoup plus nuancée
merci beaucoup
jim michel gabriel d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur inter france chapelle qui
vous êtes avocat spécialiste des
endroits des médias est en droit de la
propriété intellectuelle